Justin who do you think who do you think
cheats more men or women and do they oh
she's gonna hit us with his statistics
now
and do they again who do you think
cheats more men or women and do they
cheat differently I think we cheat
differently I think I think men cheat
more okay but we definitely cheat
differently like I feel like and I know
it's gonna sound bad but when women
cheat is worse yeah I was gonna say that
I knew you guys would say that their
argument is because when the girl cheats
it's because she has feelings for him
he's providing her something about that
but that's usually what it is it's about
like it's about emotion it's about on
top of that like as a girl like when
with a glass of a girl he just sleeps
away you can just like you can literally
sleep with us
that is not worse
take over take over when you cheat like
if you were to cheat would you cheat
with someone other than your boyfriend
no there we go oh wait it depends
I'm sorry it depends on this no I was
going to say so you're the first thing
you see is someone's attractiveness
obviously but I think if someone's not
better looking than your boyfriend
necessarily but he provides you with
something else emotionally you get what
a truck you're gonna say that's worse
right that's the point they're making is
the guy has something your boyfriend
doesn't doesn't Okay where a girl like
like okay I always say this like do you
remember the day you realized you had to
worry about ugly [__] too
[Laughter]
you said it look at it like I was like
you thought
but it's because like guys it's more of
like an instinct they're like oh God
Boop like boobs bump like ass I don't
even like see what she looks like
I'd even notice she was fat like like
that's what I'm saying like guys it's
more of just like an immediate response
where girls like we have to connect with
them on some level we have some
prerequisite for them sleeping with us
it takes a while for a girl I think men
like have you ever have any of you ever
slept with a girl that you would never
want to be seen in public with yes yeah
has always been
has always been Champions League
[Music]
okay what about you guys
he knows
I know like I was saying earlier like
there are guys that are dogs like
they'll just sleep with anything just
just because they can or try and get
their numbers up or at uel name them
[Laughter]
wait put that put that on the floor Hey
Romeo turn off the camera
no don't be shy go ahead go ahead let's
go yeah those guys obviously they'll
just sleep with girls at Uni just
because they know or they know she's
easy like they're bored or they're like
horny or whatever they'll just sleep
with her
but yeah like girls aren't going to do
that
or less likely to anyways do I think for
guys like that behavior usually
I'll say okay there are two types of
guys the guys don't have like could get
girls from a young enough age and
they're really really super late bloom
so I feel like you always go for a phase
where it's like you're just you don't
you just go for it like and then usually
that that that phase usually ends like
after uni whatever and then you're just
in life and you and you you can turn
down six whereas those guys
who are super late bloomers are the ones
that like in their mid-20s and they're
just like they will literally go
anywhere
and do anything and it's just like it's
the ones that got like they had no girls
at school and suddenly like they're
attractive now they start hitting gym or
whatever they can suddenly get loads of
ghosts and then they just like don't
know how to like control it like this
composure
I was like how do you expect to play
Champions League games if you don't play
preseason uh so you've got to build your
levels up
can I clarify let me just understand so
crazy so you gotta sleep with the uglier
girls to get to the hotter girl but if
you're not on form okay
I can't relate bro so the ugly girls are
like practice not not me that's like
it's like a friend
it's like someone else that's bad I
would never but am I wrong no okay when
I was like a younger like
it's all coming out now
no but yeah yeah that's that's
like trying to not upset the ugly girls
[Laughter]
okay
um
so okay do you guys think that
um because we were kind of talking about
how cheating is different for men and
for women right
um and I want to tie this back into
social media okay do you think that it's
cheating if a girl is posting
ass pictures on the internet in a
relationship 100 that's cheating yeah I
wouldn't say cheating cheating us like a
strong word I'd say that yeah I feel
like it's disrespectful or like yes
she's overstepped her boundary I
wouldn't say like
you know and then what's the problem
that's the thing I know it's a very
thick life about sharing it on Instagram
it's calling for attention but then you
again you are proud of your body you
want to show it if you're over showing
okay that that recalls like for
attention like you're over posting about
your ass about your boobs about your
body all the time I get it but if you're
sharing like a bikini or a lingerie
photo just you know once in a while
what's the problem with that Josh like
you are proud
I think but I think it just screams easy
to man no I think to me it's like girls
they are easy in real life it is a thing
where you like do gym and stuff and like
your personal trainer and like obviously
work your bum and that's fair enough in
it because that's part of your brand
your business if you're just any normal
girl and you're posting a picture of
your nyash then listen yes
like why are you posting a picture of
your of your behind like that's
disrespectful
that's an open invitation for hella DMS
hello story replies I think for a
premium account on Amazon free trial
facts
that was a good analogy
no but like I feel like
girls oftentimes mistake sexual
attention with like relationship
attention because like they'll put this
ass picture on the internet one that's
gonna be there forever like your kids
like are gonna see that someday is that
what a [__] what if a guy posts like a
topless pic or something when he's in a
relationship if a guy does it if a guy
does it I mean okay it's twofold right
one yeah I do think
it's I do think it's kind of douchey to
be honest
um but honestly I think it's a double
standard yeah I think it's more cheating
for women than it is for men because
most men aren't going to get girls in
their like DMs like that and I think if
you're a guy and you're posting on top
of this picture there's one or two
things do I have a Hench because you've
actually worked for it so it's just like
fair enough like you might be able to
build or whatever the hell or you're
like hell attacked and it's just like
it's art not R but you know what I mean
you're trying to say yeah but you still
wanna you're still on attention like you
guys okay it's not the same because
girls don't really see see like a chest
and are like I want to have sex with
that like like guys guys see an ass and
like the the you know it's wait so so
you play something you might get like 20
30 replies I don't know how many I
posted like a chest but you might get
like one or two if that you know what I
mean that that was the fact that we're
we're always the ones pursuing whatever
whatever you do will lead to more than
what if we do something yeah
yeah because guys usually are moving to
go as rather than girls move into guys
yeah we're we're the sales people yeah
let me know
but I think like women I've seen as more
as a sexual uh than men that's why in
general let's start there but if I see
like a male as a model like a really
nice model and I see and I like his body
you can actually get turned like in a
way like wow sexy yeah I would do him
why not like you know but like he
crosses your mindset because he does
it's not just like as a you know yeah
but okay okay but it crosses your mind
sometimes it does right but that's of
course if they see boobs and above
they're like ah you know oh my God I'll
go there I would die baby I mean like
guys have a thing such as like a sex
doll
that's the thing that men purchase six
dogs yeah yeah like a girl would never
buy that yeah
okay yeah but you don't buy your little
toys and stuff
yeah it goes have way more you live with
me you know I don't have one the [__] no
but I'm saying like men are more
attracted to like a body like that's
what I'm saying like like why do they
need that visual because like men are
more attracted to like like they're more
visual than women yeah
I mean who's gone for a guy that's ugly
but funny
that's why I feel like it's a double
standard and it's different for men and
for women
[Laughter]
now you said it perfectly you said
perfect
okay so
um do you think in a marriage it would
be better if both Partners just deleted
social media if you really want to be
married for a long time I was gonna say
I think like it would cause less stress
like maybe not Instagram because you can
use that for business or Twitter but
like Snapchat like why would you need
like your friends can text you you don't
need stuff like that when you're in a
relationship why do you have Snapchat
yeah you have Snapchat you are in the
streets
nothing good comes from Snapchat I
redownloaded it
I mean I just got it
designed for secrecy like what good can
come oh my God I need to tell you what
tell us you know you can download the
data from a Snapchat and get every
single message that someone has sent or
received ah how how you don't ask me
don't ask me oh I know how do you do it
how do you do that
um
wait can I just see my old messages or
Choice messages both if you well if you
know his passcode for no reason
I should never do that that'd be like
crazy like everything
you can see every single message that
they've ever posted yeah like I I did it
I mean I never um did that
no no but I know it what no I saw it on
Tick Tock I was like oh cool you
actually work yeah
[Laughter]
anyways I'm single now
um no but
yes no I agree Snapchat I think in
general is kind of just
deleting social media just give
just make it easier so you're not
tempted or there's no jealousy things
like that I mean you can keep Facebook
like nothing bad happens on Facebook
just a bunch of that one who still used
to be surprised bro yeah you'd be
surprised and one of the number one like
um there was a divorce lawyer that
talked about
um one of like way that couples get
divorced after like 20 30 years is
because they get a friend request from
like a high school X oh and then they
they leave the relationship for it and
then they remember all the reasons they
broke up 20 years ago yeah with that X
and then they both end up single
okay
no that yeah remember me I think social
media is just
I don't know like maybe some social
medias don't really
what's that's on Twitter I'm not sure if
you know but I think Twitter is like a
social media site where
nothing that bad happened like who moves
to people on Twitter I feel like if you
take away one then it'll just it'll just
transfer to it all social media
platforms are all copying each other
like even Twitter has stories like they
all like they're all basically the same
like when something goes well like The
Tick Tock scrolling thing they have that
on Snapchat on Instagram like they all
just start copying each other like
what's popping well and the other thing
is I think social media has raised
women's standards a lot because like
they'll get messages from guys that they
would never get approached by in real
life not even I was gonna say he was
talking about it earlier but girls can
Lich it's insane you see these people on
TV and they're big you get you can
literally just DM them and they will DM
you back not like does that happen to
you
yes or no any NBA players yeah I'll say
yes okay NFL
no no what about an actor any famous
actors yes
I won't
like that
okay okay okay all right
[Music]
wait wait
OMG what the
dmu
um
it's 2019. I think I slide it in okay
and we followed each other for a while
oh wow okay
they won't see the onesie
um
that's that's crazy but that's um the
point is it's very everything happens on
social media like it's so easy nowadays
you see these people and you're like oh
I could never get in touch with them and
suddenly you're in touch with them so do
you take that because okay I've I've um
I did an experiment actually where for a
video where I dm'd 50
um NBA players to just see if any would
respond okay and you guys can watch it
on my channel go help me get my watch
time up um please
I had there was like two or three that
responded but it's interesting because
to me I'm like I would never consider
that to be like real because like I know
he's just trying to sleep with me like I
like you're not but you're not about a
reply for him didn't you would you think
that's insane yeah but I just I don't
know like to me it doesn't really mean
anything because I feel like those guys
just do that do that with with to
everyone like you have to just have to
be half good looking and they'll
whatever but it's not like they want
anything from you they just I mean what
are your ads of locking down an NBA
player good luck even the why even the
girlfriends like you have to share them
basically you know what I mean
yeah but this is um
it's just left me
it's okay
no oh no it was on your point actually
yeah so yeah and this is why I think
that cheating
is worse and it was easier for women to
achieve than it is for men yeah on
social media that is because you said
like these high profile people would
reply to both of you yeah but if any of
us were to be um like these verified
Instagram models the chances of them
replying to us purely because we don't
have a a blue tick on social media yeah
basically zebra agreed
do you think that cheating is different
for men and for women
like do you think do you because there's
some people in the manosphere that think
that
if a guy cheats you should try to work
it out because it could have just meant
nothing to him but if a girl cheats it's
the relationship is over but that's what
we're talking about though for me if a
guy cheats on me it's over there is no
way to come back this is going to sound
really wild though yeah but like when a
guy cheats the goal is never better
looking than his girlfriend and this is
the point I was gonna make before yeah
because the guy doesn't wanna the guy
doesn't actually wanna it's gonna sound
so mad the guy doesn't actually want to
leave his girlfriend he doesn't want to
fall in love with another girl he acts
in a weird way
not those toxic what is toxic but not
those like weird ones but like
um like abusive ones but like in a weird
way the guy who still loves his
girlfriend and the back of his mind
doesn't actually want to leave her or
fall in love with someone else so the
girl he cheats on is usually Never As
Good as his actual girlfriend if that
makes sense yeah go because girls would
be more likely to
now if he was a guy you would end the
relationship and then get with the girl
you wouldn't but we don't if you if she
was if she was better but we don't have
relationships
and and that's the worst thing I Feel
Like Girls when they cheat tell me if
I'm wrong but they do it in such a
twisted way like I know so many girls
that will like sleep with guys friends
after they like broke up or if they've
seen each other in a little break you
know what I mean guys don't do that [__]
because it's just like bro I'm not gonna
sleep with your girl bro code or even
this one if you cheer your girl you're
never gonna bring that girl in the same
room as the girl you cheated with a goal
literally walk you in make you Spud this
guy she'll play FIFA and and you will
you will never know I just have to say
one thing you said broco happen both
ways
a guy's not going to risk it because
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
true that's true
very true
I've done that but
no if a guy if a guy started my DMs and
I see on his profile he has a girlfriend
I just send it to her oh as you should
we should
we should start snitching but you guys
don't Stitch because you don't care no
no no we just we just don't snitch it's
just like because if a nice girl slice a
DM but then she's got a guy you're more
like she's snitching it's going to mess
it up so you just be like you're just
chill until she doesn't have a guy and
then come back but broco doesn't exist
anymore no it doesn't no it doesn't it
doesn't it
with women whereas guy code is like it's
with yours
there's like Unwritten rules like yeah
and you've like you're in a relationship
with a girl you end it and then she's
trying to move to even if you find her
mad attractive you're not gonna be like
you still have you're gonna tell your
boy that now but then if it's a random
guy you don't know then there's no
broker he's saying if it's like your
homie they wouldn't I promise you oh my
god um experience like they will oh my
God no they'll be they'll be in your DMs
yes yes the next day
that's happening
we don't know about it's either
sometimes like a boy but the majority of
the time it's because that guy has
pressed triangle and given the free ball
and you don't even know he's literally
yeah
if you haven't seen it don't look past
and in the guys that you're giving his
Blessing yeah yeah for the other guy to
literally make his move so sometimes
I've got like a goal be like oh my God
your boy is doing this and he said you
know it's like I know and it's mad as
well guys guys
will ask guys will ask me like oh bro is
it a cool effect did you say yeah yeah
the girl fix oh like you I got with your
boy and he's not even telling you like
not like you're you're the one that
assisted your bro yeah that you said you
gave him the green light he's like yeah
yeah
goodbye okay I will say with cheating
okay if a guy cheats I mean
now
I'm Gonna Leave right and the reason
being is because I feel like like we're
not even married yet like okay if you're
doing it now like the future can't be
bright right but I think if you have a
child it's not about you anymore
so if I had a kid with someone I would
try to work it out yeah because I think
like like your feelings are kind of
irrelevant when you have a kid and I
would never want to put a kid at a St
like at every like that's how do you put
it sorry
um at a disadvantage for their life and
like a kid is at every statistical
disadvantage if they don't have both
parents in the home like they're more
like 80 percent of people in prison were
born from a single parent home
um about I mean I'm a nanny my work as a
nanny for 10 years and I've seen uh a
lot of kind of different families single
mothers both parents and I can promise I
mean my mom is single and she raised me
I I had no father present in my life and
that was good I think because he cheated
on my he my father cheated on my mom so
and she needed she never wanted to work
out and I think that's best because if
you don't trust the person that in the
back of your head you're gonna always
have trusty shoes and then those stress
issues that will
um you know lead in your head like to
travel like in the house and for this
child like to see the parents like
fighting all the time for little things
because they don't trust each other well
but that's why that's why you like go to
therapy and like find other ways to work
it out
I mean therapy yeah I just maybe one can
have that luxury you know to have
therapy or to have people around them
and to support them because we are you
know we're not all coming from the same
place right yeah but like even like
before the invention of like birth
control like honestly people stayed
together through thick and thin people
didn't just leave like like there's so
many times where their grandpa had like
a family on the other side of town
nobody knew about
right right because now these days you
know they always see an embedded option
they go so you know so don't work hard
they don't and it's not just I just I
just think like at the end of the day
it's not about you and you have children
like like why would you want to put your
kid at that disadvantage like I I know
getting cheated on is terrible like it's
a whole like that is the worst feeling
in the world like you feel like absolute
[__] but like at the end of the day if I
had kids like it's not about me it's not
about my feelings so it's about the kids
go ahead so if you're if your partner
cheated on you when you had kids you
would stay with them
but how many times let's say cheated on
you 10 times and you caught him it has
to be like a limit there is there's I
think it's like if um
he gave me something
I would leave yeah like like an STD or
something or like if um
it became like public you know I mean
like he was doing it so much like
everyone knows you know
um I don't know I'd have to think more
about it there is a line but I'm saying
if it's like a one-time thing like I
don't know men and women are different
and you you would stay with him if I had
kids I would try to work it out
I would give him a probably a chance
yeah I think everyone does mistakes and
nobody's perfect
but more than once no I would cheat on
him on purpose then my idea actually
wait wait wait
to play the same price
you pay for Apple I give you an apple
okay that's it with me
no no no well you realize that that
lowers your value like you're kind of
playing yourself because like you're
just saying oh I'm further is not like
forgiving so many times this guy who
cheats on you all the time so if just
because you have a kid I mean I don't
want my kids to be raised by a guy that
is a cheater because even just being but
then then he'll be raised by two
cheaters
to come back to my life okay
never you know never you've never done
that no I've never been cheated not that
I know I mean
um so yeah and let's pray for him if he
cheated on me and I know I'll go back to
my ex and then probably I will cheat
around him but I don't have no kids I
can do it no I'm joking okay anyway
no keep talking keep talking
okay okay so
you would if you were me
if I would work on the relationship we
have a kid and he cheated on me okay I
would forgive him once but twice
a picture hello he cheated on you again
oh yes come on come on I'm talking to
the mic talking to them
it's like that I just think that because
then you lower your my kids to follow
those steps well I know but
you're giving him more of an example to
follow okay
okay I forgive you God forgive you too
okay
we have a kid okay family let's let's
have a happy family second time oh I
will show you how to cheat then oh
I like him I actually imagined this in
my head you know
hey baby let's go to the hotel
you know five stars not not two stars
and no Motel okay I bring the handcuffs
you know oh handcuff okay I'm like yeah
let's play kinky right okay
the best looking guy I find you know and
then I [__] him you thought of my
husband whatever it is
you would okay okay let me let me just
let me just let me just get this here
let me know he feels what I felt not
just was but twice huh darling okay let
me let me let me just send you I don't
know one I feel like the guy would
probably leave oh that's good okay
okay
this is what we mean by ghost cheat
worse
[Music]
and that's it you cannot handle [__]
don't start the game that's it okay okay
but how does that help you a lot no how
does that that guy these ego is going to
be more little than his penis
[Laughter]
did this to me no I said that the words
gonna spread it's gonna be worldwide and
then
okay okay